GOOD AFTERNOON OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE FOR MONDAY MAY SIX
IS HEREBY CALLED ORDER PIZZA
VICE OF THE AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDING OF TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS
BE MAY ALSO BE TELEVISED
-- MADAM SECRETARY WELCOME BACK
AND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY FAIR CUNNINGHAM
CARILLO HERE FLORA CREATION
KAMLAGER-DOVE HERE MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS QUIRK SILVA RAMOS
RIVAS WICKS WE HAVE A FORM
WE HAVE A QUORUM AND WE HAVE
THE CONSENT AGENDA IS OUR
MOTION A MUCH HARSHER
ALMOST CERTAINLY BY MISS WICKS
-- SUPER MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
HI FULLY AYE CUNNINGHAM
CARILLO HI CARILLO I'VE FLORA
FOR I GRAYSON BY RECENT I
KAMLAGER-DOVE I AM HONORED
AT FIVE MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MATHIS SITE FUNCTIONAL
MOST CORPORATE CELL PHONE HI
SO AS SAYS YOU OUGHT TO BE
RESOLVED BY RAMOS I
RIVAS RIVAS IRON WORKS
WORK SIDE MOTION PASSED
THE MOTION IS PASSED AND --
QUESTIONS FROM HIS INSURANCE
YEAH VERY GREAT